there's a famous study in brazil uh
during cover 19 in which they wanted to
show whether or not vitamin d would help
with seriously ill uh
hospitalized cova 19 patients and my
area of expertise there is evaluating
the
study design of researches to find out
how they should appropriately be applied
and
in this particular study design was a
rather poor one because they gave
vitamin d extremely late and they gave
the precursor to the precursor to the
active vitamin d
so but the important point here
is that when you give a very large
one-time dose of vitamin d
that kicks in that fail-safe mechanism
and causes the bi the body to break down
that vitamin d and in fact the body will
continue to break down vitamin d for 28
more days
so you end up actually having a lower
vitamin d
a week later than what you would have
had if you hadn't gotten vitamin d at
all
and the other problem is that the tests
that are used to test for serum vitamin
d in the blood don't distinguish between
the active vitamin d
and
that breakdown product
so these researchers in brazil when they
tested the serum levels of these
patients said oh look but we know that
the bolus worked because their vitamin d
levels in their blood were high
whereas
likely we have no way of knowing because
it's not a very commonly used test to
distinguish between those what they
actually were finding is the breakdown
product was high not the active vitamin
d level was high and that is the
only study
that the us government has cited
relating
in
in discussing vitamin d and cover 19. so
all the other studies that showed that
vitamin d worked well
uh there were three studies out of spain
there were several from france there
were a lot of different prospective
studies
that showed that vitamin d dramatically
decreased covid case rates covert
hospitalizations coveted death rates
covet icu rates all of those things were
dramatically reduced when people had
vitamin d prior to getting cover 19 or
early on when they first got covered 19.
all of those were not even mentioned by
these government organizations instead
they mentioned only this brazilian study
in which they gave this huge bolus dose
that probably actually served to drop
the vitamin d and actually it wasn't
even a particularly big dose it was uh
in the end it was a
it only raised 80 000 so much yeah and
and you know if you throw a bucket of
water on a blazing house fire you don't
then and it doesn't put the house fire
out you don't then report water doesn't
put out fires right
it's just like that in a disease if you
act
you can put the fire out so this is a
perfect indication of what we are saying
that despite the fact that
none of the three of us would leap to
the conclusion that public health
authorities were actively
somehow seeking not to control covid but
in this case to take all of the evidence
that vitamin d positively affects
covered outcomes prevents contraction of
the disease and positively affects
outcomes in those who contract the
disease
to focus on the study that fails to
point to that result because of an
experimental design flaw is what you
would predict if you were looking to
avoid this conclusion somehow rather
than to figure out what was going on and
and to navigate as best as possible yeah
so i wanna i wanna uh stop you for a
second because
most people don't know anything
really about vitamin d
can we talk a little bit about normal
the normal interaction between human
beings and vitamin d how it is supposed
to work and then what modern life has
done
to that interaction and then what
implications it has for disease
yeah i think it's worth probably look
given that you you you look through the
evolutionary lens it's a very good way
of looking at
what was vitamin d like
you know 10 000 years ago for for us
as a species well and actually there
have been studies that have looked to
try to find tribes that live that way
now still and measure their serum levels
and they're great really clever studies
because they show us what our normal
serum levels should be and they're far
far higher than the levels that are
currently defined as sufficient uh in
almost across the board so we now
everybody who's part of this community
is pretty much on board now with uh
a level that we would target for
ourselves of 50 nanograms per milliliter
using the american units we use slightly
different units here in new europe so
which you have to multiply by two and a
half
um and yeah that's because you're out in
in the sun the summer sun all the time
getting exposed all day when it's sunny
yeah so what i talk about in my paper is
the indoor lifestyle that we now have
which is absolutely not uh what any of
our predecessors had and the change was
during the industrial revolution so
prior to the industrial revolution
virtually everyone in the world
hunted gathered fished or farmed and so
they were outside all day including in
the heat of the day now it's important
to know that vitamin d is not obtained
from the sun just any time anywhere
so uh
the rule of thumb is that if the sun is
not at least 45 degrees above the
horizon
you are not going to be able to get any
vitamin d because the ozone in the and
this is you know historically the ozone
in the air the natural
uh
atmosphere is thick enough that the uvb
rays don't get to you so you can still
get sunburn from the vitamin from the
uva race but the uv b rays that help
provide vitamin d are not accessible to
you so what i tell people is
if you want to know if you're getting
vitamin d or not it's very simple
when you're outside look at the ground
at your shadow if your shadow is not
sharp and shorter than you are tall you
are not getting significant amounts of
vitamin d that's beautiful early morning
outside is a wonderful time
enjoy the birds but you're not getting
vitamin d
winter middle of the day if you live in
a northern climate you're not getting
vitamin d
so
this is a and there are actually pretty
easy to find apps
and places you can go on the internet
where you can find out what the angle of
the sun is in your particular location
to find out whether or not you can get
vitamin d today or not but at this time
of year there is no place in the united
states that you can get vitamin d
even in the middle of the day
as well so it's worth knowing that you
might might all those conditions can be
present and you still might not be
getting enough so
air pollution i take i take a daily
supplement every day all year round i
just take more in winter than i do in
summer so
i'm also now taking uh daily supplements
as as is heather i'm i'm is uh
d minder a good app for people to use we
have recommended it
okay
a charity that was set up years ago and
they have some fantastic information for
people it's aimed at promoting
information it's called grassroots
because they've actually been
campaigning for more than 10 years to
try and get vitamin d somewhere here in
the uk and failing and in the end
decided we just have to educate people
because the governments aren't going to
help us get this message out and are
actively resisting it and have done for
a decade so i want to point out the
uh what may still be subtle for people
which is
in
almost any ancestral circumstance
the amount of outdoor
time
during the summer
would result in a production of
sufficient vitamin d which would then be
stored
in fat
and muscles yeah stored in muscles as
well so yeah it diffuses too also
basically across your entire weight all
right so the
stuff stored in fat and muscle in
particular has a special relevance
because basically we have an ebb and
flow of
available food resources in ancestral
circumstances and so what you have is an
elegant system for banking vitamin d
when it's easy to produce because the
sun is high
um and storing it in fat which will
therefore then be released as times are
tougher less is growing and there's less
sunlight so the point is it's a system
that is built to maintain an equilibrium
and those of us who are supplementing to
compensate for the fact that we are now
spending much more time indoors and i
should point out that there are some
counter-intuitive aspects of this like
window glass blocks uv
radiation and therefore even if you're
sitting in the window seat and it's
the sun is shining on you it's not doing
you any good in this regard
it's sunscreen doesn't take really any
sunscreen at all to block the uvb rays
as well
sunscreen and uh you know i was
realizing um i'm a cyclist and i
realized that even in the summer when it
might be better to cycle with a shirt
off the cultural custom seems to be to
wear a shirt and that that's probably
something that we ought to revise at
least maybe shortening sleeves or
something would allow more production
correct the other thing we're seeing is
that uh the tropics you'll notice if you
look at cova 19 rates
all throughout sub-saharan africa you're
just not finding the coca-19 rates and
we're expecting it to be catastrophic
in sub-saharan africa because there's so
little capacity i lived for five years
in a remote area of ghana
and that is a very outdoor culture the
people basically use their huts as a
place to shelter to protect themselves
from dangers at night when they are
asleep yeah they spend the entire day
outside they eat out aside they visit
outside they cook outside and in those
areas we're just not seeing kova 19.
i've got friends who work in hospitals
and clinics there and they're just not
seeing it and they should be
and i believe it's because their vitamin
d levels are high
but
in the areas that are uh heavily islamic
or have other cultural reasons so for
instance cambodia and the philippines i
know for a fact and brazil to a lesser
extent uh light skin is highly valued
and so people tend to cover up
especially the women tend to be covered
up and that's where we're seeing the
outbreaks along the equator it's places
where
people are wearing a lot of clothing
even though they're in the tropics so
this is exactly what happened with mers
do you remember mers of course the
middle east respiratory syndrome uh and
it was in fact when i did my literature
review at the very beginning of the
pandemic to look into uh previous
coronaviruses and seasonality it was one
of the first things that stood out and
it was
targeting exactly the same people who
wore full body clothing didn't get
exposed to natural sunlight and were
vitamin d deficient
and when i did the causal inference
analysis we looked at i think it's
probably the biggest causal inference
analysis ever conducted we looked at 1.4
million data points because there was so
much data coming out at that time
and
examined the geographic patterns
the virus was in
australia for example all over the the
centre of the tropics well before it hit
italy and yet there were no severe
outbreaks anywhere uh until it hit italy
all of the
locations that suddenly started having
severe outbreaks were happening north of
pretty much north of 40 degrees uh north
last year uh a couple of exceptions were
30 degrees so i i noticed early in the
pandemic uh the
disaster that unfolded in guayaquil
ecuador
now this is anomalous because of course
ecuador means equator and so from the
point of view of the angle of the sun
it's the perfect place to be guayaquil
is on the coast it's a low area but it
is very hot
and i don't know maybe you know the
answer but i'm wondering if the
prevalence of air conditioners and the
tendency of people to be driven indoors
by
heat might have contributed in guayaquil
compared to for example quito which is
at high altitude and a much more
temperate climate um there are two
factors that that might be at play there
one is that there's
a genetic polymorphism which is which
interferes with vitamin d production in
communities in ecuador
uh i i'm not the expert on that
particular thing but i'm in touch with
one scientist who is and the other
explanation as you've said is in in very
hot weather this happened actually in
arizona as well i was very surprised to
see rates going up in arizona because
the temperature was so high it was 40
degrees centigrade which is i don't know
what in fahrenheit like a billion
fahrenheit yeah
and so christine whether that's that hot
everybody goes straight to the mall
whereas and then air conditioning you
you know an air-conditioned wall this
perfect breeding ground for a
an envelope virus you know it can it's
it's dry and it's cold in it and that's
perfect uh transmission time you were
talking about italy earlier and italy's
early uh pandemic and the surprising
thing with italy
and you could see the same thing in
korea
that uh
in both italy and korea you would expect
the biggest outbreaks to be in the
biggest cities that have the
international airports
so you would expect rome to be where the
italian outbreak was but it wasn't
instead the italian outbreak was up
north
and in the mountains the same thing
happened in korea seoul did not have the
big outbreak the big outbreak was in a
smaller city
and people looked at the air pollution
levels across those countries
and the air pollution
was such that
both seoul and rome the way that they
sit on the coast
the same thing happens with houston
texas
the the
currents push the air pollution inlet
and so those areas don't have high air
pollution unlike california where the
california coast has the mountains right
behind it and california coast has
serious air pollution right along the
coast and so they found that air
pollution was a really high uh risk
factor for getting uh covet 19 and wuhan
has incredible problems with air
pollution
so is the uh i guess maybe because they
both point in the same direction air
pollution on the one hand blocks uh uv
radiation
also it will tend to drive people
indoors where they have at least some
insulation from it
well you you're not if you're if you're
living in a really heavily littered city
there's really no way to get away from
it you know that we're we're
talking about
uh
people that don't necessarily have hipaa
air filters inside their houses so um
noting is that in brazil for example
that was one of the um southern
countries that seemed to start to have a
big outbreak and did have a problem um
and that was surprising to people
brazil actually has a very well
documented vitamin d deficiency problem
in its older communities which of course
you know older people they're usually
housebound or in a home and they're not
out in the sun getting uh and there's a
very um high uh population that are
either
black or mixed race uh and
you know that your skin color will also
block you these so
early in the pandemic when i was working
with um dr karami and dr buyers we
predicted that we would see if we were
right we would start seeing higher
fatality rates in people with dark skin
and as that happened they were being
announced on the news it was another
data point that said we write about this
and it was just incredibly hard to get
people to take that seriously
um
which is very sad yes it's a it's a
politically incorrect conclusion that
there is something physiologically
predisposing darker skins people to risk
from covid the irony is that recognizing
the reason that dark-skinned people have
dark skin is to block uv radiation and
so it is not surprising in an era where
people have been moved around so they
don't live where their ancestors were
and their skin color does not
necessarily match the amount of
encounter with uv radiation that they
have that therefore being aware that it
blocks vitamin d production and
supplementing to compensate for and
supplementing i would point out can min
mean taking a vitamin d supplement
it can also mean minding the position of
the sun and very actively banking
vitamin d which is uh to my way of
thinking a much better although i am now
forced to supplement uh with diet
uh
banking it from the sun would be a far
superior mechanism
[Music]
you